the press spent almost the entire day as
you watched reporting on BuzzFeed's
false report and its implications
impeachment indictment may be a wave of
indictments maybe everybody goes to jail
well looks like not at least for now
Ethan Behrman is a progressive radio
host in California and a frequent guest
on the show he joins us tonight
so I mean Ethan could this be or let me
rephrase the question and make it a
statement this is an example of people
believing what they wanted to believe
well I think that there was some of that
however I want to say something right up
front it's it's an interesting and odd
day when I agree as much with Dan bond
Geno as maybe even more so than guy
Benson right now it because he Dan is
right we have to have some trust and
faith in journalists and there's a
problem right now where journalists want
to be opinion hosts and they blur the
line because it's exciting to share your
opinion you and I love sharing our
opinions that's right and we want to
base it upon facts and it's really
important that we have some faith
however I think it's really important to
parse the words of the attorney here the
special counsel he didn't say false not
accurate actually in a legal context is
very different from false so we don't
know and in slight deference to BuzzFeed
at this point because I am deeply
disappointed in this news coming out but
some slight deference to BuzzFeed which
is hey let's figure out what isn't
accurate before we throw all of it out
maybe there were pieces that were right
right what pieces weren't and I think
it's important to understand what is
wrong about it look I will say and I you
make a fair point there's a lot we don't
know
and I am NOT gonna get over my skis in
speculating about what did or did not
happen I don't think Russia's the
primary threat we face going forward
that's obvious but the specifics of this
case are unknown at least to me so
you're right we're gonna find out a lot
of stuff we don't know but to have
someone who would know the special
counsel take this extraordinary step of
refuting at least to some degree this
story tells you it must have been pretty
wrong why else would he do this because
he's covering
Trump probably not right yeah I mean
this is absolutely astounding as I was
coming in and seeing this news come
across I am my jaw might have been
dropping open cuz Muller doesn't talk
his team doesn't exactly for them to
come out and talk right now yeah this is
a huge deal at least we have a new it
I'm sorry we're good until we're out of
time we blue break we're going to a hard
break Ethan Berman it's always great to
see you thank you for that thanks